today I'm a show true believers we have
a guest in the fat cave and we are going
to get scary bring your freaky we're
gonna get horriffic punter ewwww
yes wordplay so yes horror in the fat
cave come on back
hello and welcome back I have a
guesstimate that cave look this is Clark
Wolfe my friend Clark will tell us where
we might have seen you before Clark
before where we can find you after you
dazzle be here today
well you could find me getting cocktails
at the bar you can find me I'm the host
and showrunner of Collider nightmares on
Collider video uh which is a weakly
genre show where we talk horror sci-fi
fantasy in movies TV comics games all
kinds of fun things excellent
now I met Clark through horror we were
both on a DVD video junket for Dracula
untold which is horrific aliy bad but
Universal decided hey let's take a bunch
of journalists to Romania because
Dracula and Romania ah yes and I think
on that trip I might have confided to
you or maybe later because we have since
become friends that I'm a [ __ ] and I
don't really like horror and she is like
the biggest horror fan that I know so
given that we are we're crusting our way
into Halloween where people are
beginning to choose for themselves what
kind of horror if big movie marathons
are gonna have weird of a discussion
about horror and find out eh
why am i such a [ __ ] um and this we
might need a couch and therapy for that
but also what I've been missing because
I have not tuned into har in a while and
I realized that like some of these
things have been both big and good yeah
and and we're gonna have little
discussion I think about the differences
between the kind of harlot I like and
what she likes and and where we are and
what you can do in our top five each of
us will have a top 5 of our favorite
horror movies so I'm a wimp mm-hmm I am
I hear you say this by me say this and
I'll tell you what because uh
I was a kid the HAR that I kind of fell
in love with was the horror from the 80s
I'm I'm an eighties kid so it was a lot
of memory I'm streets a lot of you know
like Halloween sequels Friday the 13th
Evil Dead and Evil Dead twos and those
were movies that at least to me were
were more about like both mood a little
bit of humor but the jump scare the
manipulation of horror is what I chafe
against and I do that in almost every
movie that I go to and every kind like
if I see a director who was doing
something specifically to elicit a
response that I don't feel is earned
this Spielberg is as guilty of this as
your average har direction where he does
a thing that will make me cry and I see
he's doing it like color purple is
nothing but him like just pulling my
tear ducts and making [ __ ] fall out of
them
joy and I kind of don't mind it
sometimes but I resent it all the time
and I don't enjoy the feeling of being
like heat up and hyped intense and then
when I can see all of their like alright
she's looking in the mirror she's gonna
open the mirror Oh or like crazy music
stabs like when I can see the the the
articulation of that it's when I begin
to like come on guys really yeah really
and so that's that I fell out of it
because I started to resent going to
movies and feeling like I was gonna have
a heart attack am I wrong in thinking
that that's a lot of what modern horror
has become well I mean especially if
you're gonna say that you like slasher
movies I don't think that you can hate
on jump scares as such but but no I take
your point and I think that you know
what the what the slasher boom in the
80s did I think is make Studios very
aware that teenagers and young people
we're going to pay big money to go watch
real cheap horror movies so people began
equating horror with slasher movies in
the 80s because slasher movies were so
financially successful and I think that
you know with the jump scare look I
think most people resent the jump scare
because at the end of the day you're not
it's not earned but to use your steven
spielberg example he's got one of the
couple of the greatest jump scares ever
in Jaws you know whether it's been
Gardner's boat in his head
popping up and my dad tells the story
about when he saw it my dad's like a big
guys like a former football player and
he was sitting there with Hawaiian Punch
and the head popped up and he threw a of
that you have the shark jumping up you
know when Brody's chumming out the water
so you know even Spielberg has done the
jump scare but I think that when you
take an example like Jaws that is earned
um another great example which is more
recent is something like the conjuring
you know I think James Wan with that
film showed some incredible directing
but he earned every scare that he gave
you and and truthfully there weren't a
lot of empty ones right because I
personally don't mind a jump-scare if it
yields something if something pops out
at you but it actually delivers well
that's one thing but if something you
know the cat jumps out just to scare you
because the filmmakers are lazy and
there isn't anything we don't have any
story here so cheap scare exactly then I
think that that's fair to resent that um
but there has been you know in the 90s
of course you have this rebirth of the
of the slasher movie Wes Craven
essentially and Kevin Williamson with
scream essentially tearing it all down
and building it right back up again
and then in the 2000s you know you had
the paranormal activities of the world
the found footage the ghost films but
then you also had you know the term that
I hate which is torture porn which i
think is what you might be alluding to I
do not like viscera for viscera sake you
know and I feel like there there are
moments when I had my big schism was
like when the first saw trailer came out
and I was like oh god this is a
beautifully done trailer I do not want
to have seen this movie yeah that would
have given me those images in my face
yes you know and and I and I absolutely
understand why you resent the the term
torture Paul right because it is both
reductive and also a little bit
uncomfortably sexist and almost
submissive right it's just like it's a
oh that's just this thing which horror
has always brushed up against as a genre
forever
right so yeah but like that was the I
don't need
and then like Human Centipede comes out
like I definitely don't need to see that
no one unity I'm just gonna put that
right out there yeah I totally get what
you're saying and you know it's an
interesting thing because so the reason
that I got into her in general I was a
film student in college and and and I
studied political commentary and horror
and sci-fi and I think that her and
science fiction have always been an
examination of a culture right they can
be out there best sometimes that's just
slash and burn and it's boobs and it's
blood and then you're making a buck and
that's fine too for certain people you
know no one's judging anyone's cinematic
tastes for in that regard but the thing
that got me into horror made me become a
huge fan of the genre and loved the
genre is that what scares a culture and
what actually becomes popular and a
culture at a time and what they're
afraid of says a lot about the people of
that culture and so you know you can
look back at you know West great one of
Wes Craven's most brutal films which I
think you could arguably put in that
torture porn category is Last House on
the Left but what is Last House on the
Left well it is an exploitation film
certainly but is also a remake of the
Virgin spring and it is also a strong
statement against Vietnam and the
violence that people were seeing coming
home and seeing on the news and and you
know West was very intentional when he
made that film but a lot of people
looked at it and said oh my god this is
horrifying
right um so with the 2000s and the
aughts you know what were we seeing
happen well in Western culture you know
a lot of Western countries the United
States included were involved in a war
right and there was torture being shown
on the internet on YouTube we were
learning about it in some of our prisons
I mean the term torture became and the
visuals that went along with torture
were very much a part of what was going
on in our society so with saw I will say
if you go back and you watch saw or if
you've ever seen saw you will quickly
see yeah I never seen so I love it oh
there's me
clever but I will say you know gosh it's
a million dollar movie that they made in
12 days I mean granted yes the set the
main set of the bathroom or Cary Elwes
and Leigh Whannell are chained to the
thing it's disgusting I mean it looks
like oh god where did they find this and
how did you know
and how did Wesley from The Princess
Bride end up here right this is very
upsetting to me but I will say that so
much of what they do is in hyper editing
and is in set design and is in this you
know the trap design but you see very
little and and that's something that
I've always appreciated about James um
there and as he has progressed as a
filmmaker he has shown more restraint
but I think when you go back and you
watch the first Saw movie specifically
you know it's not all there on the
screen now I will say with The Hills
Have Eyes and Alex's Hills Have Eyes and
Eli Roth's hostel those are two that
often get lumped in in the torture porn
as well but I would argue I love both of
those films and you know I I don't like
watching people be harmed and maimed for
fun that's not my idea of cake but you
should know that I do think that both of
those movies have a major statement to
make
whether it's Alec Sasha's um Hills Have
Eyes talk to taking a nuclear family
into a desert where the American
military has messed up their life and
now hey maybe they're a little angry
well geez um what does that sound like
especially coming from a French director
at the time what time of freedom fries
and freedom toast in the US and then
with hostel it's a similar thing it's
xenophobia it's the idea of these
Americans walking into Eastern Europe
they're entitled they they do what they
do and then oh maybe we're gonna pay a
little bit of a price there and and also
you know rejecting the culture and
saying well I'm American and this is
what I'm here to do so I think each of
these films actually do have an
underlying message but then you get the
Human Centipede which there is no
underlying message there yeah like I'm
all for especially genre fiction like
the the power of genre fiction
is an allegory is invoice you know being
able to like you said scratch the
surface and find something else beneath
it when it's great like it's it's the
thing that it's the it's the it's the
putting cheese on top of broccoli it's
the I'm going to get my message to you
in a way that you don't mind because
it's covered in [ __ ] cheese and in
this case the cheese is nudity or gore
or action or explosions or all that
stuff I just like and I realized that
this is a failing of mine I'm not saying
that I don't like it because it's bad
I'm saying that I don't like it because
I'm a wimp and I'm I'm often not willing
to confront that to get to the message
beneath oh but I have the utmost respect
for both filmmakers who can do that and
especially like as a as a former film
student as a person who has spires to be
making this stuff the low-budget
ingenuity of it all the idea that you
know the the absence of resources is a
it's what helps fund this that's what
helps generate this up it's what gives
it all its juice the we didn't have the
money so we have to solve this problem
how do we solve this problem and then
that solution often becomes way more
interesting than the we threw money at
it like the we threw money on it answer
is never the right answer it is always
they well I guess they made another
Godzilla movie why because they had the
money so Matthew Broderick is in it we
got Diddy to do a theme song and it'll
be awesome because we threw money at it
I totally had that soundtrack by the way
I mean yeah but I could maybe rap come
with me right now what we'll save that
that's not for you I don't need the
wallflower though good without that so
given the spirit of where we are um we
figured that we would both give like my
top five yep coming from a particularly
wisi angle and her top five coming from
a I'm all up in this [ __ ] and I
understand how it works and I and I been
sampled and become an expert in what
horror is today my list I think you'll
know this is a little bit no I'm gonna
I'm gonna just I'm just gonna preface
this by I know it is list is and we
happen to share a title which I think
for a top-five says a lot
it says well cuz we've got
right and I maybe not as we'll see as I
think I am maybe she's a little bit
whistling [ __ ] so top [ __ ] what is your
number five well okay I mean this is
like asking me to pick children
I know you realize I've this top 10 that
is fluid you know so it's so hard for me
to rank them I don't how about this I'm
gonna say I don't have a favorite okay
um but these are in no particular order
no particular order okay but I'm gonna
throw out there so what mentioned it
before Alec sausages The Hills Have Eyes
is in my top five favorite horror films
of all time it was and I've told Alex
this in but when I've had the chance to
meet him it was you know as a student
you you learn about okay well this is
what Romero was saying when he made this
or this is what Craven was saying when
you made that then there's this angst
and there's frustration that's tied up
in the genre and for me
as a college student watching The Hills
Have Eyes in the theatre I got it like
that was my four cuz I can I can look
back retroactively Lee and go oh yeah I
know what this means but for me seeing
The Hills Have Eyes in the theatre I was
just like this is how angry I am this is
how frustrated I am this is everything
that I want to say and I rewatched the
film this past weekend actually it is
unpleasant but I still love it so I'll
throw out there Alexes The Hills Have
Eyes okay my number five is not
traditionally seen as a horror movie but
the thing that it does for me is it and
and it's it's a thing that I find to be
not to the corner of the realm
but super point in almost any movie you
talk about but it conjures a mood and
the MU that akan Jers and and there's a
beat in it that is maybe the most
horrifying thing I thought of before or
seen on screen but it's seven it's David
Fincher say I love this movie and it is
so much about mood it's so much about
getting in the brain space of John Doe
but there's a sequence where John Doe is
is again he case you haven't seen the
movie what's your point why are you here
blood in case you forgot in the movie
Kevin Spacey plays John Doe who is
killing people throughout this LA scape
in the manner of the seven deadly sins
and he gets to lust and lust is the one
that [ __ ] me up because you'd never see
anything what you do is you come into
this like interrogation room and Leland
Orser I think he's behind the table he's
like sweaty and like shaking and like
he's wearing like a cop's overcoat
because he's got some bondage gear on
underneath that you can only see kind of
like sneak out every now and again and
all they keep saying is he strapped it
on me and he made me do it and and you
don't know yet what that is but you
realize that there's a dead body
somewhere and you realize that he had to
do it and the only thing that you get
really clue that you get is a Polaroid
that's only onscreen for like three
seconds of the thing that was strapped
on him and that [ __ ] me up yeah just
the idea that like we never see the act
we never see we never see what happens
to this poor woman who is the subject of
this act we never see any bodies but
it's just in our head we do the work the
power of suggestion yes like we are
active participants in the story and we
are and it's a thing that comics does
incredibly well it comments is all about
the space between panels it is the
reader giving you over giving themselves
over to the story and filling in those
blanks and that is one big awful blank
for you to have to put in your head and
keep there yeah and that that is the
kind of thing I'm like oh god that's so
frightening it's in sinuous it just it
works your way in your brain and it
stays there it's the head in the box at
the end of that movie like that's a
frightening image which you never see
which you never you see you see like
this there's like this much of a frame
of Gwyneth Paltrow's head in a box
spoiler alert Wow now like almost 20
year-old spoiler alert but yes just it's
the Gweneth head in a box movie and you
see so little of it but it registers and
it sticks with you and you understand it
and that's the kind of like oh you're in
on it like you're not complicit in this
story and you're helping me freak you
out that's why I love that movie that
scene bothers the [ __ ] out of me even to
think about it cuz it's so awesome yeah
it's really upsetting and Fincher
Fincher ventures that sneaky genre kind
of guy he's
he's I argue he's made horror movies but
he doesn't really make them nope but
allegedly Brad Pitt wants him to make
World War Z to which I will side me up
advance tickets on Fandango I am there
see I still feel I mean and I I read the
book mm-hmm and I listened to the
audiobook which is one of my favorite
things ever there's a world in which the
best version of that is like a 10-hour
mockumentary series on HBO World War Z
yes oh yes the film that we got is not
no no no it's our Center fine like I
kind of like it I do too but like the
version that for me feels like it's the
best version of that thing we're never
going to see because or maybe we will
remake remake maybe HBO when my ten
years were like [ __ ] you know what
Brad Pitt is box-office poison because
he keeps leaving his wives black whoa
what I don't know allegedly you can say
um but yes I feel like that the ten-hour
like HBO we're just telling this story
like a normal history with recreations
and like stock footage and all that
stuff just give me the fabric of that
that's what I want but that's a
digression that we didn't want to take
that's fair um so okay I'll fourth one
fourth one fourth why not it down um
it's a movie that is mixed reviews but I
love it and I think that if you go in
looking to have a damn good time you
certainly can it's like one of those fun
houses in a rinky-dink carnival that
comes to town on the weekend you go
through and you're just so tense and
then a dumb plastic head pops out and
you go ah and then you go oh I'm so dumb
why did I scream it well you have a
great time and that movie is drag me to
hell Sam Raimi's you know with Alison
Lohman and Justin log I love this movie
I love it so much um I love it because
to me it is all of the Sam Raimi's
sensibilities from the Evil Dead trilogy
but with a budget there he has a budget
you know when he gets to make the studio
movie and it is we
and it is quirky and honestly the truth
is I really identify with Allison
Loehmann's character um you know we're
both from the south and we moved to the
big city in Los Angeles and you find out
some things about her at you know in her
past that I may or may not relate to but
ultimately it's fun it's funny it's
weird it's dark and it's sam raimi just
being Sam Raimi and I really love it so
drag me to hell is one of my favorite
yes I love that like Sam Raimi with a
budget making horror is still just like
twenty four million dollars totally like
it's not like oh no we gave that dude
like Michael Bay money to make a horror
movie there you go you've got enough for
like good craft service exactly and like
real cameras and maybe a Steadicam I
don't know okay my number four yes
is it keys into my desire to both love
story and then take story apart in the
middle of it it's uh it's it's Drew
Goddard and Joss Whedon's cabin in the
woods
um I saw this this was probably the most
recent horror movie that I've seen and I
saw it only because I had to like for
work I was I was interviewing drew and
they're like well you have to come see
the movie like I don't wanna but you
have to come see the movie know you've
got to talk about the movie can I talk
about Buffy right I'll talk about Buffy
for like an hour
can I talk about literally anything else
yes for cabin in the woods so I saw this
movie and you know Liz on [ __ ] edge
the entire or the beginning of the
entire time might be I had no idea what
to expect from this film because it
presents as if it is just a straight-up
cabin in the woods with me but it slowly
works your way into it you begin to see
it acknowledging what it is and then
taking it apart while still being what
it is like I've never seen a movie do
that before like be both itself and its
commentary on itself at the same time
and by the time you make it to the end
it is both horrifying and suspenseful
and hilarious and really like knowing of
what it is and then it it also has the
balls to have the ending that that movie
should have not going to spoil that one
because you can totally watch that on
like that flicks or Amazon Prime what
and you shouldn't watch until the end
because you would never have thought
they would have done the thing they do
at the end of that movie yeah which is
the best but yeah I mean I'm just I'm
such a fan of both those guys like I'm a
Joss Whedon fanboy from like jump so to
watch him especially because Buffy and
Angel were so much about horror tropes
were so much about the final girl and
the girl who lived and the blonde girl
running from the vampires turns out to
be the one who kills the vampires and
all of that stuff to see him just like
swirl all of this into this nice like
Meatwad of joy and awesome made me so
happy you know that was a very
controversial movie for horror fans when
it came out there was a huge push back
half of the audience loved it and then
the other half kind of said [ __ ] you why
are you making like don't make fun of us
to our faces and I mean obviously I
think if you get the movie or if you
appreciate the movie you know that it's
actually it's not about that it's not
about having it fun at someone's expense
it's about saying we love this so much
but oh my god it has to die and be
reborn we all know these things like we
all were I'm with you I'm there like I
know these tropes just as much as you do
we have to kill them and I love it I
love cabin in the woods and I think it's
fabulous I think Chris Hemsworth is one
of the most underrated funny people out
there he's so good in this movie um well
I mean everybody's great in it but yeah
that wasn't it that was a controversial
one when it came out yeah I mean it's it
very much felt like the at least from
Joss and Guice perspective the like the
nobody picks on my kid brother but me
it's like but we're also in this house
like we love this stuff as much as you
do we're just both poking some fun at it
but being totally true to it absolutely
um and you read about Hemsworth like he
reminds me a lot of like that jump when
schwarzenegger turns out to have been a
pretty funny guy that you never would
have ohh in that package why would you
have a sense of humor you should like 9
times out of 10 humor is from people who
have to compensate for being the other
absolutely from being you know a lady or
a fat person or whatever it was it made
you a misfit humor is your shield and
defense for it so you should not be
allowed to be that [ __ ] handsome and
also funny I agree yeah it's just not
fair so
[ __ ] you Chris Hemsworth for being
everything for being so perfect yes we
love you I love you I felt the same way
about like Jon Stewart I was like you
know what you're handsome guy super
funny I'm just really glad you're
married and your dad may be short I know
you're short
I mean I'm also not a tall guy but like
if he and I were single at the same time
in Manhattan I would have had no chance
at all I'm sure Jon Stewart appreciated
we'd have to have that make fight in the
back of an alley or somewhere um okay so
my that was my number four did you do
you know before I did my number four I
did do my number three three three three
all right
uh this is one that we may or may not
share in common mmm but the thing John
Carpenter's The Thing so um I remember
these are in no particular order okay so
don't tweet at me and tell me whatever
don't be pushy uh but no I I love John
Carpenter's The Thing I think it is art
and I think that he would probably hate
me saying that but I do I think it is
truly his masterpiece um I think it is
above and beyond it's above and beyond
just a movie I think it is perfect and
you know what's amazing is if you know
anything about the making of that movie
you know he went back and scrapped like
half of that movie um it was obviously
it was a tough shoot and a lot needed to
be reworked and gosh when you're dealing
with practical effects and you're
dealing with a guy who at the time was
very new to the game doing these
incredible things I mean it was it was a
tough shoot by all accounts and as most
of us know the critical reception from
the fans and the critics was awful I
mean I did a piece on this a couple of
years ago where I research the response
to the thing and boy I mean usually
especially with genre at least one
person gets it right like one person
from a major outlet even if they're the
lone voice they go nope there's
something here this is special whatever
I stand alone in this you know in my in
my authority right that's the dream of
the cult is that like nobody likes it
but somebody loves it totally and boy
did that not happen
that didn't happen with the fans either
the fans hated it and carpenter to this
day I don't think I mean he talks about
it openly he's never forgotten it and
it's still I think devastates him to
this day and rightfully so he made a
masterpiece that people just did not
accept but I I think it's fabulous I
think it's brilliant I think it's smart
I think the effects are great I think
the actors are great the cast is great
and I can't say enough good things about
it
okay I will not say anything about it
because it's also on my list but we'll
get to that we'll get to that my number
three is uh it is one filmmakers best
movie he's ever made and it's also
really on in his making of the movies
bit but it is Zack Snyder's remake of
Donovan I love this movie I I was not
that big a fan of the Romero zombie
movies hmm um I appreciate the [ __ ] out
of them yeah like for what they were um
I mean especially like you know night
Living Dead and there's a black
protagonist at a time where there were
no black protagonists who were able to
function on the same level as everybody
else and the original dollar Dead has a
lot to say about sort of commercialism
and and the the 80s running rampant in
America and the material objectives and
all that stuff but there's a sense of
humor to Zack Snyder's thing and much of
that comes from James Gunn's script and
much of it comes from the actors he got
to do the piece but it moves like it
functions as both a legitimate horror
movie but also as a really stop thriller
you know and it also has again good
performances it's got a great cast and
you know whatever your feeling on your
past Ami's versus slow zombies I don't
care yeah good legs give me good Mac
just give me a sense of style give me a
sense of perspective give me give me
both a control over the word and the
over the vision the visuals that Snyder
would never again give us on screen like
he just that seems to be his best movie
so far well I think if the script really
helps yeah you know that script is a
great script and James is not only a fan
of the original source material but of
the genre mm-hmm so I think that you
know
team the team up of an incredible visual
style with an incredible understanding
and execution of the of the genre and
the writing and is this is a great
combination like Schneider is a shooter
and he shoots the [ __ ] out of this and
because he's got enough to work with it
all holds together and it's also not
overwhelmed by visual effects like it's
most of it is practical you know there's
a couple of like oh my god they're in an
RV and they're surrounded by a sea of
zombies yes there's CG and then I'm sure
there's CG in a lot of movies yeah but
it doesn't feel like there is you know
and I'm much like you know like drag me
to hell they had money but not that much
money like if they had 40 million
dollars to make that movie I'd be
surprised oh it was probably in the 20s
it was probably way less than that yet
but I just remember going to see that
movie like I was always working on her
to me weekly we're critic was reviewing
and it was like a Tuesday night at 8
o'clock the night as he went to press on
Tuesday nights so was I was just gonna
go with her because I would have to wait
for her to come back and ran through
view anyway and nothing else to do
I'll [ __ ] go see a movie fine Darla's
dental goo [ __ ] and I loved it just just
just entranced by this movie and so for
people like myself who are total wimps I
still say that will do you just fine
absolutely I think that's a great choice
everything is earned um okay my second
to the last film I'm not using my
children uh is Wes Craven scream now
this um speaking of scream so this this
is you know I have to say for me when it
comes to horror oh tours Wes is my guy
um lot there's a lot of Carpenter and
Romero and those types of people out
there but I'm a Craven person I think
Wes is one of the only people who - in
the 70s with Last House on the Left in
the 80s with the Nightmare on Elm Street
in the 90s with scream and I loved from
the from the ox red eye um so you know
he got he's just he's very good at this
stuff but the combination of Kevin
Williamson and this really again like
James Gunn loves the genre
beause the genre is able or Drew Goddard
and Joss Whedon knows the genre laws of
the genre is able to deconstruct the
genre and I think some of those similar
things that you're seeing in something
like cabin in the woods were also a play
at screen with screen the other thing I
love about it is it's teenagers Wes
always gave teenagers and young people
agency he always respected them whether
they were villains or whether they were
heroes
he always allowed them to be real whole
characters they were not waiting around
for grownups to inform them and and I
really loved that because he respected
youth and he appreciated youth and
scream is um you know ivory watch it
often and I saw it earlier this year at
a screening and it absolutely with the
exception of the way the town reacts to
cell phones which is hilarious no they
refer to them as Cellular's y-you know
where'd you get that cellular son um
aside from that the movie
holds up it is just as smart and brutal
and has something to say I love the
reveal of who the killer slash may be
killers are and and I love that they are
owning it they are not you know they're
and it's sad and it's scary what could
be scarier then then enabled white
privilege teenagers to cause death and
destruction it's horrifying
that is a harrowing question it is
scream is a barrel of laughs in a lot of
ways but underneath that surface you
know this is a movie that predated
Columbine by like two years and I think
that is really important I think that it
has something to say so I I love scream
it still holds up and Wes is our rest in
peace I love him my number two is also a
Wes Craven joint it is it is one of my
formative cinematic experiences like I
never saw the theater because I was too
young for a radio movie but I worked at
a video store when I was like
ninth grade or so like the riding my
bike to go like put a titles on shelves
to this at a mom-and-pop rental store
and I took home Nightmare on Elm Street
which was probably a mistake at 14 was
not ready for that but it was the first
time that I'd seen a movie that engaged
the thing that could be unseen Wow you
know the thing that we all share like
that's the that's the genius of that
movie is that it finds the thing that
universal for all of us and finds a way
to make it betray us and we're supposed
to be safe when we go to sleep we're
supposed to be especially when you're in
your parents house when you're with
friends when you're wherever you are
that is supposed to be where you have
control but you absolutely fundamentally
don't and I love that that movie just
tears that apart I love like just some
of these visuals that again with no
money
the I'm going to reach to the wall and
I'm going to come the club to the
bathtub like just simple [ __ ] [ __ ]
that we had just never seen before yeah
that are like elemental and primal like
that that's what that movie is for me
that movie's primal yeah and you cannot
logic your way out of something that's
primal like even though the movie will
eventually find a way to logic your way
out but it's also the ingenuity of a
teenager you know there's there's no
adult saving them in fact the adults are
the [ __ ] problem you know which again
in the 80s when children are beginning
to rebel at an age when you know their
parents who were born in the 50s did not
know what to do with the kids are the
ones who have the agency the parents the
ones who are at fault and it speaks
perfectly to a teenage mindset
especially like if you had a a
back-to-back double feature of like
Breakfast Club and my mom Street that's
the same world totally so I love that
movie yeah well to death well I also
think too you know we were speaking of
slasher movies earlier in the the 80s
you know the the and you have you know
so you have Michael Myers come out in
the 70s which carpenter wasn't trying to
create some sort of magical trope I
think he very admittedly alongside
Deborah Hill we're like we were just
trying to make a movie out of it they
just we're trying to make something but
that obviously spawned a Sean Cunningham
with night of Friday the 13th going well
hell I could do that what do I need
you know ki need teenagers I need a
location and I need a bad guy great yes
here we go mm Matt find me a match and
that's the thing is that you know
Cunningham has been that's not me
disparaging Friday the 13th that Sean
Cunningham has said this is a meat and
potatoes franchise this is what we do um
but I love Nightmare on Elm Street
because it comes along and says ok I'm
gonna do that same thing but I'm gonna
introduce mythology and lore and brains
into all of this and not saying the
others don't necessarily have brains but
this was elevated this was an elevated
slasher film and and and Friday
I'm Nightmare on Elm Street will always
be my favorite of the slasher the big
slasher franchise gotcha okay before you
do you're not number one pick yeah
were there any like honorary mention yes
that you wanted to give big shoutouts to
yes in the middle Eve I could do this
all day but I'll shout them out very
quickly uh so Eli Roth's cabin fever I
love it's funny and gross and awesome
David Cronenberg's the fly I think is
absolutely fabulous and brilliant a
poltergeist
Jobeth Williams is my favorite woman in
a horror movie ever go back and re-watch
poltergeist we forget we think of it we
remember the clown remember the hands on
the screen but this is a movie that is
intense and if you have a family if you
have kids I don't but god I feel it you
know I own my maternal instincts kick in
and Jo Beth Ann Williams is the star of
this show and we never see that in
horror movies anymore and I miss I wish
we saw more like that um Neil Marshalls
the Descent mm-hmm you've never seen The
Descent do not Google it do not look at
pictures of it do not look at anything
just watch it trust me uh and James
wants the conjuring okay I'm gonna give
a shout out to the Exorcist which I
remember seeing when I was like 12 years
old thinking to myself this movie was
made the year I was born how scary could
it be and then hiding behind furniture
that films no [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
um a Devil's Backbone I love love it um
by guillermo del toro it exists in this
world that is all mood and its death
hangs over this film like a shroud and I
love that there would be so infused by
that mood
speaking of mood The Sixth Sense oh love
it um because it is again it's so much
about putting you in that space of dread
of something is wrong here but you don't
know what and even like the hallmark of
a good twist is that you can watch the
movie again and have everything that you
saw not only hold together but means
something different while watching it
and you know Shyamalan has gotten a lot
of knocks for being so insistent on
twists and many of them don't work but
that one is [ __ ] solid six and stills
holds up and don't you ever tell me
otherwise yeah it's like a Swiss watch
there's there's no part of that that is
not machine to ultimate efficiency um
okay so number one number one let's do
it uh which was in your honorable
mention oh it's the Exorcist yeah I love
The Exorcist I talk about it a lot um
and you know the thing that I want
people to know is it's an easy number
one pick for anybody right talking about
horror movies because it is known as the
scariest horror movie of all time
but I think the reason that the Exorcist
Rosemary's Baby The Shining poltergeist
these movies even for non horror fans
right they all say oh I love that movie
or I remember seeing that movie or oh it
scared me so bad the reason these films
resonate is because they are family
melodramas first these are movies about
families and the scary stuff just so
happens to happen in the background and
the Exorcist is no exception when you
when you look at something like The
Exorcist and you have the priests you
have Karras you know who's losing his
mother and she's disappearing you
have meirin who's been fighting this
battle and now sees another child at
risk and you see chris mcneil who is a
single mother she's estranged from her
husband she is losing her daughter um
these are real family relatable stories
and I think that the supernatural
elements come second right so the movie
still holds up a thousand percent and
the older I get similar with Rosemary's
Baby
mmm the older I get the more I see the
sadder I am when I watch these movies
and more I feel them and find them
devastating and horrifying um so yeah
The Exorcist is is truly a classic not
just because of the special effects and
the bells and whistles but because it's
an incredible film yeah I mean that
that's the great part about movies that
both stem sets a time you're a different
person every time you wash it you know
and and to help chart your the evolution
of you against a movie is actually kind
of fascinating I mean like I didn't feel
that way the first time I saw that this
means everything to me now this part of
it that I overlooked when I was a kid
holy [ __ ] it's killing me inside yeah
and like that's the thing that kind of
only movies can do because they're fixed
in time where you are not and that like
alternate relationship between you and a
film is what makes it so amazing
my number one charity talk about the
thing which I love as again as we've
been talking about as a sort of
communism parable of like who do you
trust how do you trust anybody you think
you know somebody but maybe you don't it
still holds together today in a world
where we're talking about vetting people
for like religious sort of authenticity
or we're talking about building walls to
keep people away we're talking about
domestic terrorism how do you know if
you can trust the person that you think
he's known forever how do you test for
that and what the ramifications of if
you get it wrong and it's beautiful it's
so well done and it's just nothing but
tension it's nothing but like like
stretching and snapping that's what that
movie is like all of these long and Wow
what's gonna happen I think that new
judges went away like it's beautiful
that way like it's it's a it's a
precision piece of structural dynamics
and to get to the end of that movie and
to not know how that movie ends is
awesome and you know people say that
there's a give with the breath and
whatever doesn't hold up guys
nope I'm sorry you will never know you
can you can make your own theory as to
who is what and what the real and
whatever but the the breath argument I'm
not gonna down totally not real and and
be thankful that that movie was made
when it was made because there's made
today there'd be four more things that
would just answer questions you don't
need answered
didn't we see that with the remake you
know even even the attempt in the
prequel in the attempt to use practical
effects they just got CG it over anyway
yes like just sometimes a thing is it's
perfect version of itself I need no more
I need no less I don't want to know what
happens tomorrow just give me today all
right listen I think the band is going
to kick us off so we had a blast on my
heart I'm so glad that you could join me
today and help fill the void left by
Kevin while he's off making super girls
happen I'm happy to support Kevin and to
fill in for Kevin as he's going to make
one of my favorite shows yeah where can
the people find you on the internet you
can find me at clark will clark with an
e wolf with an e on the internet and you
can find me on collider nightmares every
Tuesday at 5:00 p.m. Pacific Standard
Time on Collider videos YouTube channel
woo I'm mark barnard and this has been
another episode of fat man on Batman
come find this mod cast calm for the
audio YouTube comments myth for the
video we'll see you soon
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder